foreign
Lacey is with us in Indianapolis what's
up
parents my wonderful parents have come
to me recently
um and asked to pay off my mortgage I
have about 55 000 left on my home I am
completely debt free other than that I
am a single 32 year old teacher and they
are everyday millionaires they follow
your your uh advice and it wouldn't be a
gift it would be me paying them back but
instead of owing the bank I would owe
them at a lower interest rate
um I know you don't love mixing family
and money and all of those things but I
I didn't know what your thoughts were on
this I have a great relationship with
them but I'm very hesitant also you have
siblings
I do I have a brother
um
I'll I will make a suggestion before I
say don't do this
instead instead I would recommend they
just make it a gift
and reduce your portion of the
inheritance by that so that your brother
is not cheated
okay now here's the reason
um a you're not a spoiled brat they're
not um they're not you know they're not
making your life too easy they're just
taking they're just using some of their
wealth to perpetuate wealth in their
family tree by making you 100 debt free
as a teacher at 32 which leads you into
millionaire status very quickly right
yes okay so that's what I would do if I
were them and I would never loan my kids
money and here is why
100 of the time
you mentioned your faith uh the Bible
says it never there's no caveat it
doesn't say except for Mom and Dad it
says the borrower is slave
to the lender
and so 100 of the time no matter how
nice your master is
no matter how good your master is you're
still a slave no matter how kind they
are how functional they are how good
their boundaries are you are still a
slave and you will feel it as John as
John deloney says in your body your body
will keep score and and you'll know this
when Thanksgiving dinner tastes
different when you eat with your master
rather than your mama
yeah that was what I was afraid of and I
I was hesitant as well I just wanted to
hear and it's not you and it's not you
being ungrateful and I'm not trying to
talk them into if they don't want to do
it at all that's fine too you have a
mortgage you're okay you're not dying
you're everything's good but but um I
just don't want you have such a
wonderful and you you outlined it three
different times great relationship with
them I wouldn't want to take a chance on
that
absolutely absolutely do you think
they'll be resistant at all to just
giving you the money versus lending it
nice and
um they have gifted my brother and I
both smaller portions of money in the
past just as gifts to say like put this
towards your mortgage or put it toward
whatever you need
um and and they've been very generous in
that and they're very equal this is this
is going to be weird for you so let's
change the conversation let me give you
a tool okay
blame me
whoa okay no I'm saying because if you
go to them and say Mom and Dad I got
this great idea why don't you give me
the money instead that's just that's
awkward right yeah that's weird so just
say hey I called Dave and he said don't
do the mortgage
and
um he said the only way he would do it
if it was his kids would be to give it
and if you don't I don't want you to I
don't want to ask you for that but
that's what Dave said
I feel like that's a pretty big pass
yeah just throw it up throw it off on me
I can handle it
yeah so when when my mom calls in Dave
you'd be ready oh I'll be absolutely
ready I'll be I'll be kind to her but I
will tell her the truth like I always do
[Laughter]